now the tech world kicks off this week
with a major departure at twitter
co-founder and ceo jack dorsey is
stepping down at the social media
company he will be succeeded by the
chief technology officer parag agarwal
in a press release jack dorsey said that
he decided to leave twitter because the
company is quote ready to move on from
its founders
what is the story behind this move
joining us now from denver is kurt
wagner who covers the big social media
platforms facebook twitter and snap for
bloomberg news kurt thank you so much
for joining us it's always great to see
you uh let's take a step back here give
us the quick take on why jack dorsey is
leaving the company that he co-founded
yeah i mean this is a bit of a surprise
to me um just because he has been back
at twitter for about six years and a lot
has happened in that time there have
been a lot of
uh kind of roller coaster moments for
him
um where you might have expected him to
leave and it kind of feels like twitter
has has made it through the other side
so to speak you know they uh
are shipping products a little bit
faster there were some activist
investors um who who joined the board
about a year and a half ago and kind of
wanted jack dorsey to leave and they've
even said you know jack's doing an okay
job so it was it's kind of an
interesting time but at the same time
maybe that's why he's stepping down now
maybe he feels like twitter is finally
in a bit of a good place um where he can
leave and feel confident that things are
going to continue so um you know there's
a lot to unpack here of course uh but it
is definitely an interesting move that
caught me by surprise to be to uh to be
honest well there are a lot of people
questioning and i know that it's going
to take a lot more reporting and some
time and distance to determine the
answer to this was he pushed or did he
jump and i guess one way we can kind of
try to answer that question is to look
at it from the different constituents
investors employees
users and advertisers who would want him
out who would want him to stay
well
one thing we know is that even if he was
pushed it was very coordinated right i
mean they came they have a new ceo that
they announced this morning
so it wasn't as if jack is stepping away
and they're doing some big ceo search
right so there was a plan in place
um but as you pointed out and as i
mentioned there were some activist
investors who took
seats on twitter's board last year um at
the time they were very unhappy with
twitter's business performance um you
know certainly wasn't growing in the way
that
peers like a facebook or even a snap
might be growing and so there was this
feeling that twitter was under achieving
and for a while during the pandemic
things got better and user growth was
really strong and and business growth
was strong the last couple quarters
twitter hasn't been quite as strong it's
possible that this could finally be
catching up to them and that maybe they
said hey listen you know jack dorsey
it's time for you to leave um but
i think that if you're an investor
this might be a move that you like
because while people generally like jack
the company has not really performed the
way that a lot of other social media
companies have over the last five years
during his tenure and one way to judge
that is by looking at the share price of
twitter versus square which jack dorsey
was also running he was ceo of two
companies at the same time which uh
really puzzled a lot of people because
they're saying how could you do both
jobs well and if you're an investor in
square you're pretty happy because look
at that the stock is up one thousand six
hundred and eight percent over the past
five years twitter which is the maroon
line at the bottom
has risen only 157 percent in the past
five years
in practice kurt do we know which
company he prioritized more
well what i found kind of funny here is
that the story has always been this
feeling that jack's true love was
twitter and that while he was you know
more successful at square squares where
he's he's made most of his money his
personal net worth
that there were feelings that square
from square employees and twitter
employees over the years that he would
eventually choose twitter that that's
where his heart lies
um but what we have seen over the last
year or so is that he's really really
into crypto he's really big into bitcoin
he's really into decentralization
and so in some ways it does make sense
that he might stay with square because
there's a lot of opportunity there with
with finance and and changing the way
that people spend and and share money um
between each other and so i think maybe
that aligns more with his personal
passions now than maybe people realized
a few years ago gotcha gotcha one thing
that i've read about is that jack dorsey
tended to be pretty much hands off he he
delegated a lot of the decisions
to his staff so do we understand which
kinds of decisions he led versus those
he kind of
left to his team for instance the idea
that he would
not allow donald trump the former
president to be on twitter was that his
call or was that something that his team
had to really um push him towards also
the uh the fact that he blocked new york
post links to joe biden's son hunter
biden before the election is that
something that he spearheaded or was he
pushed into that position by the rest of
his team
so he is an incredibly hands-off ceo and
and it cuts both ways you know some
people say hey this is what you have to
do if you're running two publicly traded
companies right you can't be in the
minutia of every single decision because
you just don't have the time in the day
to do that and so he did a
step back he empowered the people who
reported to him to make decisions um
the counterpoint there is like well hey
you're the ceo right you should be
making these decisions uh sometimes we
need you to make these decisions and he
didn't always want to do that and so the
donald trump one is a good example at
twitter um you know it was said and by
by people who were there and involved
they said that jack was not involved in
that decision he was alerted that the
company was going to do what it did in
terms of suspending um the president but
that it wasn't ultimately his call right
and and you can compare that to what
happened at facebook where mark
zuckerberg is just incredibly incredibly
involved in those types of decisions
very different styles there and so i
think that tends to work when you're
running two publicly traded companies it
kind of is a necessity but how long can
you sustain that at a certain point
doesn't twitter deserve a full-time ceo
doesn't square deserve a full-time ceo i
think a lot of investors believe the
answer is yes yeah absolutely and then
when you look at the reach um that
twitter has versus some of the other
social media platforms that you cover i
mean daily active users is pretty small
for
twitter it's uh 211 million as of the
third quarter
that's less than snap which is at 306
million and of course facebook is the
behemoth right 1.93 billion
users so jack dorsey hands-off ceo was
kind of considered a stabilizing force
at twitter but maybe he was too stable
maybe he was just kind of preserving the
status quo and twitter missed a chance
to do
a lot of innovative things that could
have really grown their reach
well i think twitter has always
struggled with identifying what it is
and who it's for right and i think the
reality is that it's for news junkies
it's for people like me who are
journalists who who are in the news all
day long who care about getting live
updates immediately
about things that are happening in the
world and some people are like that but
most people are happy to get their news
at the end of the day from you know the
local news station or they'll you know
open the newspaper in the morning and
that's that they don't necessarily need
those live updates and i think the other
thing that's that's in a way helped and
hurt twitter it's helped it from a brand
perspective but heard it from a user
perspective is just the public nature of
tweets right
when president trump was using twitter
everyone knew what he was tweeting
whether you had a twitter account or not
because of it because of how public it
is and so i think that again is
something that helped the brand but
didn't necessarily necessarily help the
user base because you didn't have to
sign up to get a lot of value from the
company yeah and if you're not signed up
obviously you're not seeing ads you're
not really contributing to the revenue
gotcha gotcha yeah so in many ways
twitter was influential but then you
look at the user base and it's not
really so influential because of that
public nature i just look at a recent
pew research center poll that showed
that only 23 of us adults use twitter
and that hasn't really changed that much
since 2018. by contrast you look at
youtube 81 of us adults use youtube 69
of us adults use facebook i mean twitter
has a smaller share than linkedin or
snapchat or pinterest or instagram i
know that you've written recently as a
news junkie about the new twitter uh
paywall it's called twitterblue that
gives you some premium products uh for a
subscription
does that change the
the purpose of twitter for someone like
you or is that an initial move towards
twitter doing more things to really hone
in on that very specific audience that
does rely on it
yeah i think that's i think that's an
example of twitter recognizing okay who
are our power users who who are we
building for right we are building for
those news junkies and therefore we're
going to give them kind of extra
features that uh you know most people
wouldn't pay for but those die hard
users probably will and so that seems to
be where they're leaning in now
to your point about the percentage of
adults who use twitter i would guess
it's higher in the sense that more
people probably
see tweets they get news from tweets
they just don't necessarily realize it
right maybe they're not logged in but
they're getting tweets uh on the tv or
or other people are building news
stories based off of things that have
been happening on twitter so while not
as many people again have accounts i do
think that the influence is still pretty
significant it's just how do you make
money from that and twitter has you know
admittedly not done as good of a job of
building a business around it as they
need to got you all right well one
person we haven't really talked that
much about is the incoming ceo it's
actually effective immediately so i
should just call him the ceo now uh
former cto parag agrawal what do we know
about what he brings to the table and
how much free reign will he have because
he will not be the chairman of the board
that's going to be an independent uh
director brett taylor who's going to be
the chairman of the board
yeah so uh perag has been at twitter for
a decade he's been there a very long
time he's an engineer he's he's very
smart he's very technical he's kind of
your your classic you know silicon
valley um tech guy right and some of the
things that he's been leading there have
been these these really long term
looking technical projects so um blue
sky for example is this idea that jack
dorsey has about decentralizing control
over social media so instead of just one
company being able to choose here are
the rules for social media here's how
the algorithms work um it would kind of
create a
technological solution so that um not
all that power is held by any one
company and so that is a project that
perag was working on um before he became
ceo and so you kind of get this sense
that even though jack dorsey is stepping
away
the person who's filling his shoes is
someone who understands a lot of the
kind of long-term stuff that jack was
very interested in
and um you know it's an interesting pick
because it's not someone who's very
public facing it's not someone that
those of us on the outside of the
company see very often but it is someone
who has been there for a really long
time and has all that institutional
knowledge um and you know he's not a
founder so there's a little bit of a
challenge there when you're taking over
someone else's creation but i do think
um he is a product person it'll be
interesting to see what he does with
that yeah and of course he was
hand-picked by jack dorsey and if
twitter is jack dorsey's first love you
feel like there's some continuity there
you had mentioned that jack dorsey has
been at twitter uh for six years he of
course co-founded the company and he
left for a while um in in 2008 and then
he returned
so final question to kurt is it
conceivable that we might see jack
dorsey again that this this isn't the
end of him
oh my gosh i'm just trying to imagine uh
the news cycle around you know jack
dorsey's return for a third time um
it's not impossible i would say because
i've
decided that nothing is impossible when
it comes to twitter um i do find it very
unlikely you know at this point i think
jack is 45 years old he's obviously
extremely wealthy i think when he came
back to twitter you know there was this
feeling that he wanted to right the ship
he wanted to kind of get twitter headed
in the in the right direction again and
you know in a lot of ways he did do that
and so i'm not sure that he has anything
to prove in the way that he did when he
when he came back in 2015 so while i
don't think it is necessarily impossible
uh i would say it's probably very
unlikely at this stage you know just
given his age his focus um his interests
and of course the fact that i think he
kind of accomplished a lot of the things
he set out to accomplish when he came
back and so um i would be shocked um as
shocked as i am of these leading i'd be
even more shocked if he were to return
someday right right well and at least in
this case he's he's picking when he's
leaving he's going out on a high as
george costanza would say bloomberg news
technology reporter kurt wagner thank
you so much for joining us on giving us
your instant analysis of the ceo change
at twitter jack dorsey is out and of
course the chief technology officer
parag agarwal is in